what did you decide on showing today at
WonderCon compare it and how does it
compare to what you've been doing on the
other at the other cons well this is
today WonderCon we're showing a piece
we've never shown anywhere before and
we're showing the piece that we showed
at Brazil comic-con but now it's longer
and the visual affection work more
completed almost entirely completed in
that sequence it's mixed differently the
music's all in so it's the first time
for people seeing that that space clip
that's early on in the movie as well so
it's it's a it's a lot of new material
it's less than like 20 minutes or so
worth of footage you showing 20 minutes
in so right it's about 20 minutes where
the footage I'm looking around to people
I think that's right
yeah I mean listen we're we feel really
confident about the movie we want to
want people to know that we want people
to see the tone of the movie the vibe of
the movie the scale of the movie and so
we brought some pieces to to give an
indication of that where are you at in
the editing process done in terms of
editing the the picture of the movie and
we've been locked on the film for a bit
and now we're just in the final we're
all mixed for the sound in the music
we're just in the final stages of
dropping in visual effect shots a few
that are still being worked on what
ended up being the big overcoat did you
have a hurdle in the editing room cuz I
speak to a lot of filmmakers and people
and in the editing room there's a
sequence I think they got but it
actually didn't come together there's
something that just has to be overcome
what was the thing you guys had to
overcome in the editing room if anything
I don't think there was a single
singular sequence that was I mean every
sequence is challenging when you're
making an ensemble movie right because
like you've got all these different
characters to juggle that all in this
case of all these different powers and
you want to give them equal time you
want to make it feel like in this case
in this movie they're working as a team
for the first time really that we've
seen in these films at the beginning of
the movie and even at the very very end
of the movie and even when they're
fighting against each other they're
split into teams so there's a lot of
that balancing editorially we have in my
estimation the guys editor in the world
Lee Smith who's Chris Nolan's editor won
an Oscar for Jang Dunkirk should won an
Oscar for Inception just in
extraordinary brain and a real partner
to me and hutch in this process to
somebody I came to really rely on to
tell story I think the toughest thing
editorially for this film and to me was
the biggest challenge in writing it and
even in making it is to balance
the tone of the film between something
that I really wanted to be way more
grounded and real and intimate and
emotional than we've done in any of the
x-men movies other than possibly Logan
but that's not really an x-men movie you
wouldn't have like an ex jet in Logan
you wouldn't go out to outer space and
Logan but to balance that really
grounded naturalistic way of filmmaking
with the interstellar you know alien
plot of this film that is about cosmic
forces and aliens from from another
galaxy to be able to balance those two
things to have a coherent tone is
something that was the challenge of the
movie and something that we really
worked hard to modulate to make sure
that one it never tipped the other in
the wrong direction
one of the things about the film as far
as I know is at some point there'll be
two groups one group for gene one group
nervous about gene if you will talk a
little bit about how you decided which
characters to put on ones on which side
yeah I think because the whole
orientation in the in the telling of the
story was to be grounded and real
emotionally and psychologically that
part of what I liked that Simon did in
the writing and the and the decisions
along that that question was sort of
determined who should be on what side
based on their relationship specifically
to Jean and the way in which her
behavior was affecting them so it wasn't
a function of going okay we really want
these three guys on this side so we'll
find a way to justify it it was because
the the incidents of the movie
specifically sort of the the Jen's death
and the way that that played and
resonates throughout throughout the
family how does that provoke different
members of the group to react and you
know part of what we wanted to explore
was a much more realistic approach to
navigating a crisis you know do you do
you run from the fire or do you run into
the fire and and how do you decide you
know what role you want to play relative
to something really dire and and I think
that's part of what I like most about
the film is the willingness to go to
those places and and also kind of to
double back for a second on the question
you asked the other thing I thought was
really notable about what Simon has
achieved with this
is in that editorial balance he was
describing and trying to try to find the
balance between the jeans story and
having an alien plot come in there was
there's a secondary application which is
is he's completing the storytelling for
each character right it's easy to
relegate supporting characters to kind
of little little snippets and and you we
get away with it in films all the time
it's harder if you're really gonna tell
the story of a family to actually
complete each individual families story
so that you feel there's a there's a
completion to each each character and I
think that's another thing that
editorially really proved to be
challenging and yet I think is really
satisfying in the movie listen every
movie is gonna have massive action
set-pieces when it's a movie like this
but for me the stuff I enjoy the most
or like the character scenes with the
banter between characters that you maybe
don't get to see so talk a little bit
about maybe are there certain
relationships on-screen or certain
characters on screen having cool fun
conversations or dramatic conversations
that we've never seen before in a
previous x-men movie there's a lot of a
lot of character dialogue scenes in this
film I'd say probably more than we've
ever had in Xmen we've before despite
also having massive spectacle and scale
like you said I was more interested in
the character work probably for my
writing background and because I just
you know as a director for directing his
first film you probably are hard-pressed
to find a first-time director that has a
better cast than this one
any director that's a better cast in
this one but if you were to say to me
hey the first time you direct you're
gonna have Michael Fassbender Jennifer
Lawrence James McAvoy Nicholas Hoult
Jessica Chastain so if it's on down like
the list is insane it's like any I would
take any one of those I really wanted to
showcase their acting ability I wanted
to actually see them as performers and
not just a stunt performers
though there is plenty of that so for me
the the the dialogue and drama scenes
that are the most interesting are the
ones where you don't expect the dynamic
of the scene meaning there's a scene
between Charles and Hank where Hank
really goes at Charles about you know
sort of what Charles's ego has done to
the x-men you wouldn't expect to see
that in a movie for the most part Hank
has been really subservient to Charles
and this is for the first time him
challenging him this is scene between
Jeanne and Eric Magneto where they
really also kind of go toe-to-toe and
deal with what it is to sort of face
their own inner demons in darkness and
that was really interesting to me
there's like throughout the movie these
sort of just surprising pairings between
characters where they really get to act
four three four five page the dialogue
and you see these great actors go
toe-to-toe in a scene and for me that
beats the pyrotechnics of any movie how
is it listen when the first x-men movie
was made there was never a thought of
this is gonna be some massive franchise
with all these movies and possible
spin-offs how is it in making a movie
like this where you're sort of thinking
about all these other movies that have
come before like the the you know what I
mean and trying to figure out continuity
and how much are you sort of like [ __ ]
it we're just gonna make a good movie I
mean I think ideally you do both right
like I'm aware of the continuity because
we've worked been working on these
movies hot just at the head of the
studio since x1 me as a writer since x3
so it's 15 plus years of our lives I
mean most of my adult life if you can
call my life remotely adult um but uh
but so you know we we are aware in our
DNA of the continuity as much as I'm
aware of like milestones in my
children's lives
has become my extended family but when
you sit down as a writer when you sit
down as a director working with actors
you're not thinking about three movies
ago you're thinking about how can I make
this scene the best possible scene in
actors and thinking about four movies
ago and actress thinking about this
moment how do I make this moment real
how do I understand this moment
emotionally so really there there isn't
like a [ __ ] attitude there's just
like we know this stuff in our DNA so
it's going to inform for me the writing
of it and the way that I even direct the
actors but when you're there on the day
you are not thinking about 15 years ago
you're thinking about 15 minutes ago
obviously we know that Fox and Disney
have gotten married or merged I don't I
didn't hear about this right exactly I'm
just curious if either of you have yet
to ask or have you asked yet for a free
annual passport to Disneyland I haven't
but it did occur to me this morning as I
was driving down here that it was
probably time time I came back to
Disneyland
you know courtesy of the new mothership
this is not a plug because the Disney
phox merger but I actually go to
Disneyland probably like every other
month this is part of what I meant but
not really having an adult life
I love Disneyland I'll go with my kids
I'll go with my friends I have yet to go
alone because that seems creepy but I
love love Disneyland I go a ton and
they've been very generous to me in the
past even before the Fox merger because
I've done movies over there with not a
free annual pass but helping me jump the
lines we're gonna say the the greatest
thing that I've ever done is I did the
Zootopia junket in Florida and they gave
us a fast pass at a 10 on it and we went
and jumped lines like you can't believe
and I will ever forever be grateful it
was amazing yes right I can see by that
smile he has also experienced that for
the both of you is there a favorite ride
at Disneyland as literally as he was
thinking I'm gonna give Hodge a second
to think about this because I don't have
to take a second think about this as you
were saying that about Zootopia what I
was thinking is when we when I say jump
lines the my greatest fondest memory of
taking advantage of the generosity of
Disney was um being on going on Space
Mountain five times in a row without
having to get off like Space Mountain as
from childhood to like I say sort of
adulthood has always been my favorite
ride I love that they brought Star Wars
into it but even before Star Wars Space
Mountain was it for me so I would
literally just go on that all day if I
could and I've tested that before it's
awesome see I don't have to think about
it either for reasons that might
surprise you which is I actually have
not been to Disneyland wait what ever
ever Wow so so I'm literally
flabbergasted by lives you live in
Southern California right you live in
the world like how do you live in the
world and you've never been a Disneyland
forgets I think also discovered
something that you too didn't know about
each other true and there's not much of
that either I'm honestly honestly
floored right now look I honestly feel
like I don't know you by the way I
figured out who you're bringing to
Disneyland in the not so distant future
for sure
I'm like blow his mind but I'm gonna
make you wait in lines because that's
the authentic experience at Disneyland I
really I really can't believe it by the
way it's true right I'm stunned so if I
definitely have to ask you guys though
and I'm sure you've been asked this
already today but
I'm curious what's gonna is there any
update on New Mutants because a lot of
us are wondering if it's gonna go to
Disney Plus if it's gonna get released
in theaters is it still gonna do
reshoots because all of us are curious I
don't have any updates to give and on
how the Disney Foxx merger will impact
the movies that we already have made
movies that were in the midst of you
know developing movies that we were
close to getting made I don't know the
answer yet is the honest is the honest
truth but I think we'll know in the very
near future so um I know someone who
hypothetically saw test screening of New
Mutants and they really liked it they
just said it wasn't scary the way the
studio wanted to make it quote-unquote
scary so but he said it was like really
good he really enjoyed it so my question
is do you feel like if you don't do any
reshoots that you have a movie that can
stand up for itself
yeah I'm really I'm really proud of what
Josh Boone did on that movie and there's
a lot of it's a really powerful film so
the fate of that film we'll find out but
it's a movie that we all put a lot of
passion and time into and is a very
different kind of movie and I think
that's the fun of making these films is
and and hutch to experience this more
than I did though we were both producers
on Logan he was really the primary
producer in that film part of the fun of
making these movies I did it with
Deadpool as well as exploring different
tonalities like Logan was a Western
Deadpool was you know in our rated
comedy New Mutants is a horror film this
film that we just made to me is sort of
a psychological thriller even though
it's got all these other elements so
every time we make one of these films we
try to explore different genre and I
think it's really cool and fresh that
New Mutants is I think really the first
time in a comic book movie certainly a
comic book superhero movie that it is
embracing the horror genre I really want
to see it so bad especially just I the
worst part is knowing that there's a
completed movie there I know somebody I
listen he doesn't give me and by the way
we know each other I don't get anything
literally nothing that is outrageous
that is not true and outrageous I feel
terrible right now I'm gonna make sure
Disney does not give you any more passes
to Disneyland
they give me actually that's true they
don't give me anything for Disneyland
separate department that was me right
exactly exactly so what's going on you
talked about doing 355 what's going on
with that the plan is to make that movie
this year
3:55 is this spy movie the jessica
chastain and i actually came up with a
night for the idea for while we were
making Dark Phoenix and then Jess is
just a force of nature Jess with a
little bit of my help but mostly all
just as fortitude
put it together with like the most
extraordinary cast of actresses Marion
Cotillard Lupita Nyong'o Penelope Cruz
fan bingbing Jessica obviously and it's
a very different kind of spy movie and
I've I love spy films so the idea of
doing something they could like disturb
and deconstruct and hopefully change the
path of those movies going forward being
an all female driven film is cool so
we're gonna try to make it this year do
you where are you in the screenwriting
process we have a script that we all
really like and the actresses like and
I'm in the process of doing some
rewrites on it
got it and is the cats that you
mentioned they're all like for sure
they're interested they're all for sure
more than interested they're like
committed to the movie and we just
started talking to actors to play some
of the male characters - there are some
male characters now movie I'm already
disappointed with you I believe I could
be wrong about this but is multiple men
still something going on or am I wrong
about this like I said you know we have
a lot of movies that we're developing at
Fox in the x-men universe and we'll see
just what that process is going to be
like going forward given the merger so
what is it for the two of you you're you
have your hands in like 17 different
things I'm just curious what other stuff
that you are excited about that's
bubbling up and how does are you still
sort of like at the studio and it's sort
of like a pause button while things are
being figured out or is it like are
things starting to move ahead now that
like they've signed on the dotted line
certainly for me it is a little bit of a
pause only only while one we wanted to
see how this went through and did it
actually close there were times where
that sounded like maybe you wouldn't and
- until it did there really was not
allowed to be any conversation about
what was wanted or would be expected of
Fox post a merger until the merger
clothes told like we could go whatever
that was and then secondly it's gonna
take a little time I think to see the
strategy both get expressed through the
top of Fox and then trickle down to all
of us in terms of how you know how and
what they want and in what forms so from
my own part it's been nice to have the
movie to focus on because you know
having been busy there for a long time
it was strange to know how many people
were sort of in a bit of limbo while all
this was playing out
and for our part we've been pretty much
completely obsessed with this yeah same
I mean you know I've projects at Fox and
a lot of them are moving forward you
know hiring writers getting new drafts
going out to directors stuff like that
and so Fox is in operating studio within
the larger studio of Disney now and
we'll see like hutch said like what the
actual ins and outs are what ultimately
the personnel of Fox looks like because
obviously they're still in the process
of figuring that out as well but and I
have like you said it as you know I have
projects elsewhere and there's things
that I'm excited about I mean my life
really has been dark Phoenix for quite a
while now and it's obviously coming to
the culmination of that many year
process of working on this movie so
that's been my primary focus I saw you
know that Twilight Zone is something
that I'm really excited about and starts
comes out this Monday April 1st which
people thought was a joke because it's
April Fool's but it actually is not a
joke um and that's been great fun to
work on with Jordan and I've other
things I'm working on but this is this
has really been my sort of life slash
wife for the last three years I actually
want to ask you real quick about
Twilight Zone you obviously had you have
I don't know how many episodes are in
the season ten episodes for a season so
how much have you already had the
network's it cuz there's a lot of buzz
on the show a lot so have you already
had the network say to you hey so we're
thinking we might have another season
you better start writing I don't know
what I'm allowed to say but certainly I
guess I can say that they're very
enthusiastic about the show and we have
started talking about how we would do a
season two if if there were things that
we would do differently and
probably the only thing that we would do
differently is try to give us a little
bit more time we realized in making
season one is and we managed to do it
but it was a lot of scrambling and a lot
of hustling from people to get shows
done when you're doing an anthology show
especially if you're trying to do it
with the level of quality we made this
show you're making a mini movie every
week you're basically making a pilot
every week as opposed to a normal show
where you have standing sets you have a
standing cast you're having to recast
every episode you haven't like build and
use new sets for every episode that's a
lot and so having more prep time is
helpful but you know the studio's
networks really happy we're really happy
with it we had a lot of fun making it
we've had a lot of actors we had a lot
of actors and first season raise their
hands and say they wanted to be in a lot
of them ended up in it some of them
didn't so we'll have them for potential
second season and there's a lot more
actors seeing this sort of vibe and the
buzz around the show that have raised
their hands and want to be in in a
season - yeah I cannot wait to see it -
thanks man I got to stop with you guys
and just say that I anytime you want to
show me the movie I'm ready anytime cool
just let me know and we will show it to
you before it comes out and have a great
panel thanks man